So, ich bin nochmal am Start und wisst ihr wer auch da ist?
Der Apisolier-Champ ist auch am Start. Der liegt hier gerade rum, den brauchen wir heute bestimmt nicht, ich bin doch gerade so aufgefallen, dass der ist auch da, ja.
Vielleicht brauchen wir den morgen, aber eher nicht. Nachdem ich mir keine Netzwerkkabel selbst mache, brauchen wir das morgen wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Aber gut, dass er mal da ist, ne. So, also, übrigens habt ihr schon gesehen, wer hätte das nur vermuten können. Also, wer, wer hätte denken können, dass das nicht erreicht wird.
Also, ganz ehrlich, ich bin echt schockiert. Ich, ich hab, ich hab wirklich gedacht, diesmal schaffen wir's, ja. Also, wer hätte damit rechnen können, kann ich gar nicht verstehen.
Es ist, es ist, glaube ich, das 14. Breitbandziel oder so, was wir nicht einhalten. Ja, by the way, Chet ratet mal, ratet mal, wie viele Breitbandziele haben wir schon, haben wir schon geschafft.
Also, pünktlich zu dem Termin, wo sie angekündigt waren. Null. Ähm, ich glaube, ich glaube, falls man das so nehmen kann.
Wir haben damals ISDN-Einführung angekündigt und geschafft. Aber ich glaube, das war's, ey. Ja, Patrick, ich hab's aber, ich hab's aber erst nachher gesehen.
Ich hab, äh, auf, ich hab Message vom Sebaro gesehen, hab ich gerade das re-tweeteste mal. Jetzt weiß ich auch, wo das Sebaro das her hatte. Kann das sein, dass ich mich ein bisschen...
Also, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder ich höre besser als sonst oder ich bin lauter als sonst. Diese zwei Varianten gibt's.
Wartet mal, ich muss mal kurz so machen. Jetzt einfach so übersteuern, nicht? Okay. Ähm, ja, anscheinend bin ich lauter als sonst.
Vielleicht höre ich heute auch einfach nur besser. Das kann natürlich auch sein. Äh, nö, das passt eigentlich alles.
Haha, ja, keine Ahnung, ich, komm, ich, hört sich für mich lauter an, ja. Ja, übrigens 2030, Keque, wer glaubt, wer glaubt denn da noch dran?
Ist das richtig dumm? Ich hab auf die OrnCustom-Firme erst mal geflasht. Jetzt höre ich, jetzt höre ich besser. Also, ich mein...
Also, mein, erstens, erstens, es sind noch vier Jahre hin, ja, bis das vorbei ist.
Das heißt, man ist sich jetzt schon sicher, man kann, ich mein, man könnte ja versuchen, in diesen vier Jahren endlich mal, ich bin mir sicher, man kann in vier Jahren unglaublich viel erreichen.
Man guckt euch mal die Chinesen an, die in zwei Tagen irgendwie fünf Krankenhäuser bauen, um es jetzt mal übertrieben zu sein. Also, man könnte, wenn man will, bestimmt in vier Jahren, vielleicht nicht 100%,
aber man könnte willen, demonstrieren und zeigen, guck mal, wir meinen's ernst. Und das Problem ist ja, das ist das, was ich gestern auch gesagt hab, wenn man ab, ups, wenn man abgehängt ist und man möchte,
man möchte aufholen, dann hilft das nicht, wenn man in fünf Jahren das macht, was die anderen vor zehn Jahren gemacht haben, nein, man muss das in zwei Jahren machen, quasi.
Also, nicht was die schon gemacht haben, sondern was die anderen in fünf Jahren machen, muss man in zwei Jahren machen, sonst holt man ja nicht mehr auf.
Und das kriegen wir halt nicht gebacken und bis 2030, alter, 2030, der lebt wahrscheinlich 2000, ich weiß nicht, wie alt ist der Typ überhaupt?
Ich hab keine, wie alt ist denn der?
Der Typ lebt vielleicht nicht mehr 2030. Was sind das für Versprechen?
Also, ich weiß auch nicht, also, es ist einfach Fail.
Wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen um das, auch Kirby-Wintermusik, das, das klingt gut. Siehst du, das ist ja heute, hat's bei euch auch geschneit.
Äh, das ist Secret of Mana, oder? Das ist 100% Secret of Mana-Musik. Ja, ja, hör ich sofort raus, hör ich sofort raus.
Exquisite.
Nee, das ist mir zumindest, ich, ich, ich brauch, ich brauch Big Brain Kirby-Musik.
Jawoll.
Hört sich fast ein bisschen an wie dicke Barge Volksmusik.
Okay, sehr schön.
Was übrigens, was übrigens auch der Witz ist, also, wenn das ernsthaft, wenn das ernsthaft Wahlkampfstrategie ist, dann fällt ihnen wirklich nichts mehr ein.
Weil, wie kann man ernsthaft was als Wahlkampfstrategie verkaufen, was das, was der eigene Fail der letzten Jahre nochmal besonders hervorhebt, ja?
Man sollte ja eigentlich von ausgehen, Wahlkampfstrategie ist was, was einen hilft, dass man besonders gut dasteht.
Aber wenn die das jetzt sagen, dann gestehen sie sich ein, ich meine, die waren in der Regierung die letzten, frag mich nicht, 12 Jahre oder so.
Irgendwann war auch mehr FDP, ich weiß nicht mal wann das war. Also ich war irgendwie 12 Jahre oder so mit in der Regierung.
Also sprich, wenn man das jetzt als Wahlkampfstrategie nimmt, dann bedeutet das ja im Endeffekt, dass sie, dass sie automatisch sagen, wir haben es selbst verschissen.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine gute Wahlkampfstrategie ist, nochmal darauf hinzuweisen, was man eben nicht geschafft hat.
Ja, das ist...
Das war heute bei uns auch so, aber es ging, musste langsam fahren.
Okay, je nachdem, wie viel es ist, kannst du es auch nicht raus, ja klar, verstehe ich, aber so viel ist bei uns ja nie.
Ey, die Idee finde ich gar nicht so übel, die Idee finde ich gar nicht so übel, das kehrt ja mittlerweile auch in vielen Unternehmen ein.
Dass es nicht nur quasi, wie soll man sagen, Qualitäts- und Fortschrittskontrolle wie auch immer gibt für Leute, die quasi praktisch was arbeiten, sondern auch für Führungskräfte.
Das ist jetzt bei uns beispielsweise auch Thema Qualität in der Führung verbessern und sowas.
Also sprich, die sind auch schon langsam aber sicher auf den Drichter gekommen, dass nur wenn da irgendwie quasi, wenn man was managt, dass man nicht das automatisch immer perfekt macht.
Also ich bin jeder Meinung, also auch quasi Manager und Führungskräfte müssen sich irgendwie an irgendwas messen lassen, ja.
Ich höre heute echt besser Leute, ich glaube mein Headset ist...
Nee, nee, nee, wisst ihr was, ihr hört mich normal laut, aber meine Replay-Lautstärke ist glaube ich aus irgendwelchen Gründen höher als sonst.
Also danke schön für den Twitch Prime-Sub.
Warum ist meine Einspiel-Lautstärke heute höher als sonst? Das verstehe ich nicht so genau.
So, ich habe jetzt mal ein bisschen volle Pulle, volle Pulle, ein ticken leiser.
Ach was, scheiß drauf, passt schon.
Gut, also wisst ihr was wir heute machen? Wir machen heute was ganz furchtbar brain dead.
Ich installiere mir ein paar Raspberry Pis, weil morgen kommt mein Switch.
Ich habe mir den hier bestellt und ich habe mir gedacht wir packen den mal zusammen live, also ich habe zwei Sachen, die wir morgen auspacken.
Wir packen das mal live aus, dann ist wieder Hand League angesagt.
Ich habe hier, ich meine ich habe mir nur nicht umsonst das Setup aus Tisch, Elgato Ringlight und Kamerahalterung gekauft, dass wir das nicht ab und zu auch mal verwenden, ja.
Also das Ding packen wir morgen aus, probieren es aus.
Das da und das, ähm, äh wie hieß das Ding?
Warum kein Ubiquiti Zeug, weil das in dem Preissegment und mit diesen Features schlicht und ergreifend nicht vorhanden ist.
Ich habe einen Ubiquiti Switch mit 12 Ports, das ist aber komplett andere Preisliga.
Das Zeug hier kostet alles um 100 oder 100, unter 100 Euro und der Ubiquiti Switch kostet 500, ist leichter Unterschied, ja.
So und den da, also die zwei Sachen packen wir morgen aus.
Und wir müssen das ganze, Switches kannst du auch mit Ansible bespielen, ne, ja kann ich, aber mach ich nicht.
Ich klick da drei Sachen an und dann bleibt es für immer so.
Ich muss ja nicht am Tag 50 Switch provisionen.
Mikrotik sackt eh ein bisschen, würde mich wundern, ja würde mich auch wundern, wenn das, geht das?
Die haben so ein bisschen Eigenheiten.
Die haben ja auch so eine komische, so ein komisches Scripting Interface, was echt gewöhnungsbedürftig ist.
Mikrotik, die, das ist glaube ich eine Polt, nee, nee, nee, Tschechen, Polen, nee, Lettland oder so, kommen die glaub her, ne?
Lat, Latvian, was ist Latvian, Estland, Lettland, Litauen, da blick ich nicht durch, äh, Riga, ja was ist das auf Deutsch?
Lettland, Lettland.
Genau, so, also, aber anscheinend, RouterOS Plattform, doch, das scheint zu funktionieren.
Ah, CLI Connections.
genau so also aber anscheinend router os plattform doch das scheint zu funktionieren
CLI connections das ist jetzt an sich nicht so schlimm
CLI connections heißt im endeffekt über SSH das ist jetzt nicht so wild
stimmt das ist router os stimmt du hast recht
du hast recht ja nö da nicht
vorbei aber brauche ich eh nicht juckt mich juckt mich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht
also den hier könnte man provisionen damit den hier nicht das übrigens der unterschied
bei mikrotik css sind reine reine switche mit switch os und also im prinzip sind das
alles reine switche aber das ist der betriebssystem unterschied also sprich hier läuft nur switch
os drauf das ist wirklich total basic du kannst auch keinen firewall regel oder sonst irgendwas
machen dafür ist es deutlich einfacher finde ich zu konfigurieren für switch geschichten
und das ist das full blown router os von mikrotik mit allen möglichen scheiß drin allerdings
muss man auch mal ehrlich sagen die dinger sind von der cpu her nicht darauf ausgelegt
großartig firewall regel und routing zu machen das können die das können die aber das ist
von der cpu her wahrscheinlich in switch zeigt mal was ist es denn für eine naja gut
ein paar ich sag mal so ein paar netze ein paar routing regeln und ein paar firewall
regeln kann er mit der cpu auch ab also das ist jetzt kein totaler rohrkrepierer die hatten
teilweise früher switches mit irgendwie 200 megahertz cpu die in software absolut nichts
auf die reihe gekriegt hat mit der cpu kannst du zumindest kannst was weiß ich kannst 15
firewall regel rein machen es geht immer noch gut auch bei ordentlich traffic aber viel
mehr ist da nicht die bräuchte man ab upstream ne brauchen wir nicht das wird ja nämlich
bedeuten dass ich das machen muss so und die wie gesagt den den habe ich schon hier die
können wir theoretisch auch heute angucken aber wozu wir können morgen auch alles auf
einem machen und den habe ich hier bestellt der kommt morgen an zumindest sagt ups das
mit dem fortran stream das ist noch nicht sicher keck weight ich glaube also nachdem ich mir
nachdem ich mir das letzte mal schon kobold geben musste und das eklig war fortran muss
so echt nicht sein ja ich habe ich habe das einfach mal so gesagt das heißt ja nicht
dass ich das machen muss was interessiert mich was interessiert mich was ich da vor
dem monat erzählt habe das schon ordentlich bei uns was nicht so viel ja ja ich weiß man
sieht mich in total vielen videos in manchen sogar komplett das check plus keiner nicht
nur bei mir muss man kurz durchscrollen max agi aber ich habe es ja falsch ich habe es
ja falsch geschrieben meiner wäre gewesen ja jetzt anzeige ist raus hier erpressungsversuch
ja viel glück was schreibst du was schreibst du ich habe alles da drin ja ich habe alles
da drin wie wie ich das mache ich copy paste das man kann auch einen browser add-on verwenden
nee den gab es noch nicht ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich das machen darf ich wollte
mal den twitch support fragen ob das ok ist weil ich darf natürlich mein 3ds flaschen
aber ich weiß nicht ob ich das zeigen darf ja ropsee dann glhf ich habe irgendwas übersehen
gerade im chat hier zeig mal ja warte ich game stop so ich glaube ich habe nichts übersehen
es gibt einen browser add-on für keypass ja ja gibt es aber nutze ich aber nicht
ich habe es zumindest nicht gesehen ok ich kreufe jetzt mal runter jetzt fangen wir
mal an gibt es keypass fürs handy ja gibt es auch wobei ich da vorsichtig wäre prinzipiell
nicht alles aufs handy sünden nur weil man sünden kann weil ich meine die meisten passwörter
braucht man auf dem handy schlicht ergreifend nicht was brauchst du für passwörter auf
dem handy du brauchst die youtube app was kein problem ist die merkt sich das e-intern
und kann es nix dagegen machen paypal vielleicht ab und zu mal amazon merkt sich den kram auch
alles in der app also für was braucht man da passwörter großartig auf dem handy ah
hier link in excellent mal mal zu falls irgendwas gespeichert hat man weiß ja nie den desktop
den räume ich garantiert nicht auf der beste desktop außerdem sieht der desktop ja auch
nur wegen euch so aus na guck mal das sind alles irgendwelche komischen emotes die ich
brauche excellent kamera produkt foto ordner wozu was mit euch los guck mal das ist viel
besser so weil wenn du hier nach versuchst wenn ich am hackermann gif suchen kann ich
einfach hackermann gif angeben und hab's gefunden wenn ich in ordner gehe muss ich noch unter
ordner aufmachen das ist total bescheuert ordner wozu was ist der sinn von ordner
foltex suche foltex suche ich mein hier habe ich gar kein desktop gibt kein brauche ich
net foltex suchen gut ist nur noobs haben die benutzen folter übersichtlichkeit ne ist
brauchst du nicht ja ich spiele poe aber die sie sind aber nicht gespielt um ist ein
schachbrett eine gute frage ich glaube das war mal ein kameratest das war mal ein kameratest
jaja ob der bewegungs ob die bewegungserkennung kommt ob das die bewegungserkennung das das
checkte ordner ordner ist nur was für windows noobs also braucht man nicht komplett useless
einfach einfach foltex so guck wenn ich irgendwas suche hier oh das war jetzt ohne was einzugeben
ok ich suche jetzt ich suche jetzt read me am start also wozu wozu braucht man ordner
es ist auch so übersichtlich genug ja monarch s read me ja meine ganze heim automatisierung
kann ich nicht zeigen weil da liege ich zu viel so wir müssen mal kurz das aktuelle
espion runter dann was du bringst nicht mehr espion heißt sondern raspberry pi o s light
schön dass du am start bist da auf x ich hoffe das richtig ausgemacht warum ist die musik
auf einmal zu laut paper please raspberry pi immer schon alles für noobs wir machen
die old school variante dd ne machen wir gar nicht wir verwenden den elektronen kui was
hatte ich auch nicht viel besser ist ok ich spule mal vor weil das andere ist garantiert
nicht mehr so laut die können sie nicht entscheiden so download wo ist es da perfekt reicht jetzt
wundere als spit ja ich habe nämlich in raspberry pi 4 und raspberry pi 3 und ich mache das
auf beide drauf und danach testen wir mal ob mein 2,5 g adapter funktioniert das können
wir heute ausprobieren ausprobieren der bananen lord römische zahlen also was ist das 20
23 ich habe kein schimmer römische zahlen in 2021 alter hätte das mal den römern gesagt
die endlich geköpft klar so römer haben keine leute geköpft die haben gerne leute mit dem
sperr ersperrt dies war ja war ja human schon ja bananen lord dankeschön für den primes
ab ja vu ist ripp guckt euch das mal an die haben es verschissen und ich weiß auch genau
warum sie verschissen haben also meiner meiner ansicht nach warum sie verschissen haben und
das ist folgendes auflockt ein die haben es verschissen gar nicht mal wegen der mod der
mod ist geil das erste problem was sie haben ist kein anti cheat das ist gar nicht so ein
großartiges problem das hauptsächliche problem ist keine gescheiten server der server hier
ist prinzipiell nicht schlecht aber absolut keine ich kann nicht mal sagen ob es keine
fähigen admins sind oder gar keine admins die da sind die da spielen weil in der regel
ist das einfach nur totale zerstörung aber komplett fünf runden am stück von einer
seite bis ich eventuell mal ein paar erbarmen zu switchen aber meistens verlieven die leute
instantin server warum soll ich ubuntu jetzt auf einmal runterladen was ja nein nein nein
nicht das da ja wunderbar und ich habe so ein bisschen die hoffnung vielleicht kriegen
sie das mit dem reality projekt hin ja aber das hätten sie machen müssen ganz ehrlich
du kannst nicht erwarten dass die leute sich bei einem spiel was zehn jahre oder so alt
ist jetzt nicht ganz acht jahre alt neun jahre zehn jahre alt ist kannst du nicht erwarten
dass die leute sich da erst noch mal ein paar monate lang weil das ist ein altes game das
kennen die mit nicht richtig funktionierenden servers und komischen rules jetzt rumschlagen
also meiner meinung das habe ich übrigens auch gesagt bevor das ganze released wurde
wo ich wo ich gesagt habe hier daran könnte das fehlen du musst von anfang an zwei drei
offizielle server stellen offizielle server gut moderiert gut amministriert sinnvolle
plugins und das wichtigste konsistentes regelset also du musst im endeffekt drei server stellen
die mehr oder weniger ja mehr oder weniger vanilla sind mit eben den verbesserungen wo
man richtig die vorteile daran sieht also zum beispiel du kannst ruhig ein bisschen suppression
weg machen du kannst sonne weg machen du kannst screen shaking weg machen du kannst auch waffen
ruhig dem dem medic geben die der assault hat und sowas aber der rest das sollte relativ
standard gut gebalance des battlefield 3 sein das kann vielleicht mal ab und zu eine nachtmerp
laufen haben oder sowas um zu zeigen was cool ist aber die hätten eher zeigen müssen so
nach dem motto mehr tickrate und kein plaufilter und keine shaking und vielleicht ne custom
perk und sowas aber irgendwas irgendwas konsistent ist und was was läuft 234 vielleicht offizielle
server 23 du machst du machst du kannst nen rush server machen mit 32 48 du könntest
nen conquest machen und das reicht erst mal eigentlich eventuell noch für die ganzen
hardcore für die ganzen basher leute noch ein tdm eventuell noch ein vierten mixed mit
den besten mit dem best of oder so und man dann wollten kann conquest oder rush vielleicht
sogar mit mit 70 dann aber das hätte man machen müssen das hat man das war essentiell
meiner meinung nach die haben auch das problem dass das spiel aktuell die ganze zeit crash
nach ein paar runden und deswegen das tut mir leid für die die haben sich sicherlich
saumäßig viel mühe gegeben und das ist spielt sich besser als das original ich hab letztes
mal wieder was bettel noch gespielt es hat ein paar probleme man merkt dass das spiel
an vielen stellen gar nicht für 60 tickrate aus ausgelegt ist aber es spielt sich finde
ich unbestreitbar besser wie das wie das wie das original gerade keine explosionen mehr
und weniger suppression und über den plaufilter kann man sich jetzt streiten und auch auch
auch dass ich das alles direkt anfühlt meistens wenn die hits registriert werden es ist schon
cooler aber ich finde es halt immer schade wenn leute sich so viel mühe geben und dann
nichts bei rauskommt weil man an so naheliegenden sachen nicht gedacht hat deswegen ich flame
ja immer ein bisschen gegen stonks leute aber eins muss man sagen ohne mist wenn ihr jemand
seid der technisch richtig gut ist dann ist die chance relativ hoch dass ihr kein guter
stonks verkäufer seid das ist einfach so es gibt ganz wenig leute die sagen eine gute
wie soll man sagen eine gute führungskraft oder so gut guter manager sind und guter techniker
in einem guckt euch mal Elon Musk an zum beispiel der typ hat bestimmt technisch keine ahnung
wie man raketen baut oder autos baut oder sonst was aber da trifft die entscheidung und managt
die sachen ganz gut so der braucht big brain leute die die technik können es funktioniert
ohne beides nicht der wäre ohne technik leute und er hat mit sicherlich einer der besten
techniker paar der besten techniker auf der welt wird das ganze nicht funktionieren oder
hat auch ein paar projekte wo ich mir relativ sicher bin dass sie nicht funktionieren werden
aber da hat auch schon gezeigt dass er sachen wirklich gut hinkriegt tesla haben sich die
leute früher kaputt gemacht kaputt funktioniert spacex haben die leute am anfang gesagt null
funktioniert funktioniert da ob starlink ordentlich funktioniert und ob ob
dings hier wie heißt das dieser wacke um tunnel dieser dieser wacke um tunnel ob der richtig
funktioniert habe ich auch so meine zweifel er hat er hat für den manager sicherlich
viel ahnung von der technik aber der könnte keine rakete bauen darum geht es heißt du
brauchst immer leute die gute gute verkäufer manager entscheider leute sind und leute die
gut technik können also beides in einem funktioniert nicht sehr selten sehr selten zum zumindest
guckt euch die google gründer an zum beispiel mal die google gründer haben das richtig
gemacht die google gründer hat ein geiles produkt haben erst mal gesagt haben erst mal
gesagt sie wollen sie wollen schnelles sie wollen schnell schnell geld machen und wollten
das an jahu verkaufen jahu war dumm falls du bringst ja nach jahu noch jemand kennt
das war die da jahu wollte das nicht ich glaube für zwei millionen oder so ultra billig jahu
hat gesagt hallo euch wollen wir nicht ok paar jahre später hätten sie das ganze noch
mal kaufen können dann für ich sag jetzt mal irgendwas ich weiß den preis keiner und
dann für traf 50 millionen wollten sie immer noch nicht und jetzt ist die jahu halt am
arsch also sie haben erst mal versucht schnellkode zu machen gute idee gehabt techniker am start
wollten das relativ günstig verkaufen jahu die wollten nicht so was die google leute
richtig gemacht haben die beste entscheidung die haben realisiert ich habe vergessen wie
sie heißen sehr geil irgendwas und ich weiß ich weiß nicht mehr wie die google dudes heißen
ist aber auch letztendlich egal und die haben eine sache realisiert die haben realisiert
sie sind gute technik leute aber keine zumindest noch nicht supergeilen stonks leute und sie
haben sich damals erik schmidt hieß der typ glaube ich geholt und haben gesagt ey wir
brauchen einen der managen kann und letztendlich hat der ja auch google dann zu dem gemacht
was es letztendlich ist bis jetzt die google leute wieder selbst zurückgekommen sind aber
die konnten quasi in dieser zeit von von einem der besten lernen und sind jetzt selbst big
brain stonks management leute ok aber die wenigsten techniker sind das eben und dazu
kommt es halt ich weiß gar nicht wie ich ursprünglich drauf gekommen bin also sprich wenn ihr guter
techniker seid ist die chance dass ihr kein das ist die chance hoch dass ihr kein guter
verkäufer manager seid und dementsprechend wenn man irgendwas machen will ist es immer
gut man hat jemand dabei der stonks man ist ja wegen vu genau und deswegen das hat meiner
mein auch vu gefehlt die hätten so eine art community manager gebraucht das hatte der
entwickler oder der erfinder mehr oder weniger selbst mitgemacht die hätten so eine art
community manager gebraucht der auch wirklich hergeht der jack frax anschreibt und irgendwelche
leute ein bisschen die werbetrommel rührt und das aber und das aber halt mal ein halbes
jahr vor release schon das hätte das hätte sein muss sie hätten bestimmt mitgemacht es sei denn es sei
denn die haben was bei bei ea unterschrieben dass sie motz nicht zeigen bei jack frax könnte ich
mir das so nee nee nicht check wie heißt der andere wer hat letzten sind video gemacht jack
frax hat ein video gemacht level cap nicht umgedreht level cap hatten wie ich weiß es nicht der der
kein video gemacht habt das könnte ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen ja die brauchen ja keine finanzielle
mittel du findest garantiert leute guck mal wenn du wenn du freiwillig leute findet die sich da
jahre lang beschäftigen du findest garantiert auch leute die spaß daran haben so ein projekt
ein bisschen wie sie ein bisschen marketing technisch voranzubringen und dafür nix wollen
du brauchst dir keine profi marketing agentur so und das haben wir machen müssen und sich im
gleichen zuge mal überlegen müssen wie schaffen wir das dass die spieler von anfang an anfang an
eine konsistentes spielerlebnis haben was ja so nicht gegeben war weil der spaß nach wir spielen
unfertige mods ist halt nach zwei tagen raus und da brauchst du 234 surfer mit konsistentem rule
set was funktioniert und die kannst du auch nicht einfach live patchen oder feststellen die leute
das spiel kackt ab das müsstest du irgendwie verzögert machen mal ein surfer probieren wenn
der zwei drei tagen läuft macht den anderen surfer wie auch immer deswegen das ist das problem es
gibt bestimmt auf dieser welt unglaublich viele produkte die technisch extrem geil sind aber total
untergehen weil sie keine passenden verkäufer am start haben oder keine passenden marketing
stonks leute so gerne ich auf die also gerne ich so ein bisschen über marketing leute sonst was
flame und die meisten sind da bei den meisten marketing leute habe ich halt auch den eindruck
sie können noch nicht mal das sie sind zu nichts fähig sie sind noch nicht mal für ihren job
fähig aber es gibt auch ein paar gute leute wenn du da welche findest die dann auch irgendwie zu
dieser firma und sie zu dem produkt passen dann bringt das auf jeden fall was weil die techniker
alleine können es einfach nicht ok wir flaschen mal nebenbei zwei raspberry pies oh leute von der
sd karte habe ich ihn hier noch war das mal von der sd karte wir starten jetzt erstmal elektron
ui zum flaschen was ich voller witz ist warum braucht man program mit einem mit zwei gigabyte
ram um eine micro sd karte zu flaschen wir können auch die d drauf machen also was habe
ich ihn hier am start ich habe noch ein paar ss ein paar micro sds also ich habe noch 20
gepackt die will ich jetzt aber auspacken 16 g haben 16 g was das hier 8 g übelster billig
krab 8 g und 16 g komm ich nehme die ganz billige 8 g mal gucken ob die noch funzt
flaschen wir das ganze mal ob die passt überhaupt nicht mehr in den reader rein
auch jetzt keg weight es ist gemounted ja
flasche file downloads wo ist es
flascht mal beim welche micro sd karten also wenn ich will also auf den pies die
ich lange im einsatz habe verwende ich die hier weil die dinger halten dass man noch
nie einer kaputt gegangen ist ein bisschen teuer aber die sind echt gut für die anderen
habe ich eine mischung aus billigen was das zahn disk und kingston da sind wir aber da
sind wir aber auch schon welche kaputt gegangen ich finde next next klaut mist alternativen
näher kommt darauf an was du brauchst wenn du den zink willst kannst du sie feil zünke
sing gibt es viele alternativen für den zink für kontakte und kalender gibt es auch eigenständige
kalderf kater fast auch immer surfer oder noch andere lösungen und klaut es auch krepp
aber ansonsten mache ich next dort nicht und auch nicht ich habe zwar im einsatz aber nur
weil ich zu faul bin es endlich abzuschalten sie um stick kloom stick weiß nicht tritt
ich bin dankeschön für den massive prime subscription ja next klaut ist gerade dabei
auch klaut ist gerade dabei irgendwas zu rewriten keine ahnung wird aber ich immer noch mist
scherwigs da ist das den weg hierher gefunden hast die sd karte ist aber ultra schnell das
ist jetzt so eine billige kingston 8 gigabyte karte mal hoffentlich ob die ob funktioniert
hast du eigentlich eine freundin ja meine ps5 lull cringe antwort cringe panes champ cringe
so wo hab ich jetzt den wo hab ich jetzt die kiste am start ja super ich bin super schlau
leute gewesen so war so war big brain richtig treikopf bin ich gerade ich hab ich wollte
jetzt die raspberry pies flaschen aber ich hab die raspberry pies hier gar nicht hingestellt
ich weiß gar nicht wo die sind
next klaut arbeitet jetzt mit der telekom zusammen das macht es aber nicht besser aber die haben
sich gefunden die haben sich gefunden
by the way plot twist ich hab noch nicht mal eine ps5 und ich kauf mir auch keine ps5
auf flash mal hin ja ich sehe auch den sinn da aktuell nicht es gibt ja nicht mal spiele
für
es gibt ja noch nicht mal spiele für also es lohnt sich noch nicht mal das einzige was
gibt es dark souls nee demon souls remake wenn man das mag das ist aber auch alles mehr
gibt es nicht
laut preischen bis die ps5 nicht verfügbar das ist richtig die gibt es auch nirgendwo
so leute ich muss mal kurz gucken wo ich den raspberry pie hin hab oder die zwei ich hab
noch einen dreier und vierer gefunden kann ich euch mal kurz zeigen also was ich damit
ausprobieren will morgen ist folgendes wie gesagt ich hab mir hier zwei switche bestellt
und was wir mal ausprobieren werden ist folgendes
wir testen mal morgen was das ding für module was das für module verkraftet ich hab offizielle
ubiquity module ich hab direkt attach module da und nen sfp plus auf aort 45 adapter mal
gucken was das alles frisst und dann gucken wir mal wie man da so wie lands und sonstige
sachen in switcher erst einrichtet hab ich noch nie gemacht da reicht auch da reicht
auch der pie 3 und 4 für die kriegen zwar maximal 1 gigabit durch der dreier weniger
aber das reicht dafür uplink testen wir dann mal hier über den windows rechner oder über
die vm mal gucken da hab ich ja auch 10 g dran können wir dann direkt dran stöpseln
und ja mal gucken bin mal gespannt
ach ja und ich hab nen adapter usb 3 2,5 g 45 mal gucken ob den der raspberry pi erkennt
und ob der router damit zünkt da bin ich mal gespannt ob die 2,5 können das ist ja immer
so ein bisschen 50 50 chance ob das klappt so hat er jetzt fertig geflasht da validate
aber leute ich muss mal kurz die raspberry pi suchen geht schnell ich weiß wo die sind
also hoffe ich wenn die nicht da sind hab ich problem
exzellent ich hab sie guck mal ich hab einen frisch verpackten ich hab heute die kamera
nicht an weil ich dachte man braucht die nicht ich mein stellt euch das einfach mal vor
ich hab jetzt gerade einen frisch verpackten aktuellen pie 4 mit 4g und noch einen in so
einem offiziellen pie gehäuse usb stick drin wo ich nicht genau weiß wofür der da ist
pie 3 das reicht und sogar ein offizielles raspberry pie netzteil da kann ja nix schief
gehen jetzt also da gibt es heute nix spannendes zu sehen in der richtung ich werde den kram
jetzt flaschen mal gucken ob der gig ob der 2,5 g adapter funktioniert in der zwischenzeit
können wir ein bisschen chat gucken also wie gesagt next out finde ich ziemlicher crap
habe ich ja gerade schon gesagt doch also aktuell habe ich ganz normal hier mein bio dynamics
headset auf der hat der hat so ein bisschen watte hat so ein bisschen schaumstoff drüber
aber da hat es nicht so einen fetten popschutz auf meinem mikrofon was ich verwende um die
videos aufzunehmen da habe ich so ein pushell drüber ja hab ich hab ich hab ich komplett
im stream installiert gibt es im archiv wie gesagt die samsung endurance karten sind
richtig nice 15 19 prozent auf was was soll ich beim saturn kaufen ich glaube ich habe
die letzten 15 jahre nix beim saturn gekauft hatten wir schon ja pains jam da kommt eh
nix gescheites bei raus next cloud ist ehrlich gesagt also ich weiß nicht warum die ins
business wollen die sind noch nicht mal komplett stable genug und und feature mäßig gut für
ein heim gebrauch was wollen die im enterprise umfeld ja
was mit der kirby musik los jetzt übertreiben sie es aber ja das das habe ich also das könnte
man machen aber die sache ist die ich brauche keine ps5 was nehmen wenn nicht next oder
on cloud erst wie gesagt es kommt darauf an was du haben willst habe ich ja gerade schon
gesagt wenn du nur sync willst gibt es genug wenn du kalender willst gibt es auch was wenn
du diese ganzen anderen halbfertigen apps willst ja dann musst du next cloud verwenden
da kannst du alle für nehmen die brauchen nicht viel aber payo lohnt sich nicht mehr
so wahnsinnig twitch block da gar nicht mehr richtig also gar nicht mehr und mit youtube
hatte auch probleme aber youtube soll wohl angeblich mittlerweile wieder halbwegs funktionieren
aber twitch kannst vergessen deswegen lohnt sich das meiner weile noch nicht mehr weil
amazon langsam im updaten ist also das ist tatsächlich technik sachen sind bei mir tatsächlich
ultra aufgeräumt also die die kleinen teile da habe ich extra so ein snipe erstes snipe
auf fack das war ich doch jetzt mal log in nicht alter guck mal ob es so standard ist
wie immer 0w alter ist immer das gleiche passwort ja jetzt schon ich habe den ganzen krempel
hier drinnen von shellies bis raspberry pies led strips und sonst was da steht dann auch
dabei in welchem in welchem fach das drinnen ist guck mal hier rein steht das nicht dabei
genau da stehen da auch so dinge drin wie fach 1 fach 2 wo es drin ist da ist noch nicht
alles drin aber ich bin eifrig am eintragen dass mir die sache auch relativ easy findet
das ist sehr praktisch muss man echt sagen weiß man genau wo wo zeug ist sogar mit anzahl
und so ja gut das kostet ja auch 300 euro oder so also das hat gefälligst hat gefälligst
eine ordentliche qualität zu haben dass jetzt würdest du lieber darauf losprogrammieren
oder die db ne weißt du was ich machen würde nachdem man selten abschätzen kann von anfang
an was man eigentlich braucht ich würde erst mal drauf losprogrammieren allerdings ich
würde es so anfangen dass ich db migrations per script machen kann da kannst du das nachher
umziehen oder aber solange du noch am programmieren bist stell einfach dein framework ein dass
bei jedem programm start die datenbank neu angelegt und gesiedelt wird das ist auch auch
wirklich ne ne drauf los programmieren es ist es ist meiner mein nach kaum möglich wirklich
im vorfeld dass sich 100 pro die korrekte datenbank struktur zu überlegen weil man nicht genau
weiß wie es wie es wird also ne das ist kein ne ne das ist das das ist das das ist das
piloten hetzer oder so von denen ich habe das da das ist quasi ein dt 770 mit halbwegs
ordentlichem mikrofon dran oder guck mal sogar billiger geworden moment das ist ein äußerst
schlechtes foto von dem das sieht so billig aus also ich habe noch die erste version ich
habe noch die erste version mit diesen ja die da mit diesen diesen was ist das carbon
look oder so finde ich nice wobei meine ja doch genauso doch genauso sieht das aus das
richtig huge mesh optik die neuen sehen finde ich nicht mal ganz so cool aus aber sind immer
noch gute headsets nexot für backup nein würde ich nicht bei backup würde ich definitiv
nicht über nexot machen also für backups ist zynk an sich nur bedingt geeignet weil
wenn du auf einer seite aus versehen was löscht es ist auf der anderen seite auch weg so fände
es an ist dass das problem an zynk also für backup würde ich es gar nicht nehmen ich
würde das nur nehmen für wie so so in etwa backup light also sprich wenn du einfach nur
das allerwichtigste zynks so dann passwort safe und vielleicht notizen und so was das
kann man machen aber so richtig großartiges backup würde ich würde ich da auf keinen fall
drüber machen backup würde ich also wenn man wenn man ordentliches backup machen will gibt
es da eh nur eine wirklich sinnvolle strategie für für einen gebrauch dies nicht total ausufert
und die aber trotzdem doch ziemlich sicher ist unabhängig jetzt von der software man einsetzt
du hast das ding einmal auf dem rechner wo du es brauchst du hast das ding einmal bei dir
auf dem nass oder sagen wir mal auf der extern festplatte liegen und du hast das ding noch
einmal oft seit gesynkt das ist das ein das ist das einzige wo du dir wirklich sicher
sein kannst also ich würde so machen wenn ich den stink normales windows hätte und möchte
möglichst brainless das backupen da würde ich die free variante davon nehmen ich mach
das mit borg backup ja aber für die für die leute den kommando teil nichts ist nimmst
hier den agent free free agent agent oder irgendwie so ist das ding genau und dann backups
du auf dein nass um netzlaufwerk und auf deinem netzlaufwerk lässt du einmal in der nacht
einen backup in die cloud laufen und da kannst du dir überlegen ob du wirklich alles backupen
willst oder nur spezielle sachen also ich bin dafür in die cloud wirklich dann nur die wichtigen
dinge an wichtigen dinge zu backupen also sprich auf dein nass kannst du schon komplett das
betriebssystem backup machen aber in die cloud weil es eben einfach geld kostet würde ich
sagen ok da sollte man sich vielleicht noch mal angucken ob man vielleicht nicht alle
fotos nimmt sondern plus die wichtigsten familien fotos die man unbedingt behalten
will oder dass man zum beispiel sein shadow play ordner mit game recordings rausnimmt
weil die muss man auch nicht doppelt backupen in die cloud aber für alles was extrem wichtig
ist muss man das an drei orten haben nämlich auf dem rechner wo man es braucht auf nass
und oft seit bergab in der cloud nur dann kannst du dir wirklich sicher sein dass nichts
passiert und ein sing sing ist genauso schlecht wie next cloud wenn es um backup geht weil
wurde das jetzt gefragt ich muss gleich mal gucken weil sing ist halt für solche backup
geschichten schlecht wenn du nämlich auf der einen seite was löst ist halt auf der anderen
seite auch weg sing sing kannst du für password manager und so was verwenden ja ja das ist ok
den solltest aber auch noch mal so gebacked haben vielleicht auf dein nass weil wie gesagt
dass das sing ist schlecht als als alleiniges backup sing ist ganz gut dafür wenn du wenn
die ein rechner verreckt und du brauchst hast noch auf dem anderen dann hat er läuft ja
nicht die gefahr ich lösch aus versehen oder so das geht ja nur um es kackt jetzt ab ich
habe es direkt noch auf einem anderen aber wenn du wirklich backupen willst gibt es
eigentlich nur die variante du hast einmal auf dem rechner wo du es brauchst du schiebst
einmal auf der nass und macht einmal oft seit bergab verschlüsselt wohlgemerkt ja am besten
mit wie ist das was rustic nee wie ist das wie ist das dieses cloud sing ding die er
clone mein ich nicht rustic er clone mein ich genau das ist gut für oft seit backup
auf cloud die unterstützen auch so ziemlich alle möglichen backends da kannst du nämlich
low brain wm verwenden auf deinem windows da musst du nämlich nichts machen das kann
jeder einrichten und hast du schon mal gebacked auf dein nass und vor deinem nass kannst du
per clone auf jeden x beliebigen oder fast jeden x beliebigen cloud anbieter sünden
verschlüsselt wohlgemerkt was das wichtige ist cloud backup nie verschlüsselt weil wenn
ihr wirklich meine passport txt auf dem desktop habt wollt ihr die nicht unverschlüsselt
in der cloud haben und dann macht ihr verschlüsselt auf seit bergab erstmal erstmal die alibaba
cloud ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht was ich davon gerade die habe ich mal verwendet für
s3 storage aber die s3 das ist trotzdem nur noch relativ teuer wenn man echt terabyte
weise braucht deswegen würde ich sagen oft seit ja die sind gut die sind gut solang man
die solange man die das ging früher zumindest nee das nee ach quatsch nee das ging nicht
das ging nicht das unlimited geht nicht zum mountain und deswegen hat es gesagt genau
da musstest du den ihre komische software für verwenden und das fällt bei mir raus
weil ich will ich will das sicher verschlüsselt haben von open source software dass ich sicher
sein kann der cloud anbieter hat echt keine chance da rein zu gucken das kann man natürlich
auch machen das kannst du ja das geht auch du kannst ihr könnt auch ihr könnt auch
wenn ihr irgendwie einen freund habt also wenn ihr wenn ihr in der echten welt noch
Leute kennt ja könnt ihr auch mit dem ausmachen dass der eine raspberry pi mit festplatte
bei euch hinstellt und ihr eine raspberry pi mit platte bei ihm hinstellt dann müsst
ihr aber gucken wie macht ihr den upload und sowas alternativ was auch eine möglichkeit
ist wenn man wenn man oft seit auf die old school variante macht ihr könnt natürlich
auch die festplatte verschlüsselt festplatte verschlüsselt das ding einmal in der woche
kopieren und das irgendwie in schließfach legen oder zur oma bringen oder zu den eltern
bringen oder so das könnt ihr auch machen wichtig ist nur dass die festplatte nicht
auch im arsch ist wenn das bei euch mal hochwasser ist oder oder oder brennt oder irgendwas
deswegen macht das ist ja grad der witz von offside backup das macht es jetzt nicht sicherer
wenn man eh davon ausgeht dass nichts passiert daheim ja die musik oder wird zu anstrengend
gerade ja bei denen hatte ich mal was aber die sind für reines back ab ein bisschen
zu teuer na guck da bezahlst du 6 euro pro terabyte das ist das ist echt ok ja aber
wenn jetzt jemand sagt hey ich brauche aber 12 terabyte offside storage offside backup
storage dann kostet sie viel aber ich sag mal die meisten leute kommen mit einem terabyte
locker hin wenn man jetzt nicht wirklich jeden scheiß singt oder nicht jeden scheiß scheiß
offside backup also einen terabyte daten die wirklich wichtig sind die man nicht verloren
will wo man sich den nochmal so den das dritte backup gönnt dass das offside backup gönnt
die meisten leute kommen nicht über den terabyte ja wenn ihr jetzt natürlich faul seid wie
ich und sagt hey ihr wollt eins zu eins alles da sinken ohne euch gedanken machen zu müssen
was ihr habt ja gut dann müsste halt mehr geld ausgeben aber ein terabyte reicht dicke
normalerweise wirklich dicke das heißt ganzen isos raus ganzen downloads raus ganze ganze
gameplay recording videos raus was auch immer das müsst ihr nicht unbedingt offside backup
das reicht so als auf dem nass da ist weil wenn wirklich mal eure wohnung abbrennt dann
glaubt mir dann sind die fortnight gameplay backups das kleinste was ihr habt wichtig
ist aber halt dass die sachen wo ihr echt behalten wollt dass die nochmal offside backups
sind down pc gut das ist das ist zu das ist zu big brain für 90 prozent der leute ok
jetzt war mal weiter also wo habe ich immer ein pay hier also haben wir erstmal den vierer
war der vierer kriegt die bisschen bessere mikro sd weil ich weiß gar nicht habe ich
habe ich so ein comic hat er hat er bei standardmäßig eine sd karte drin so eine nupes sd karte
das ist nur wenn man es im bundle kauft also ich krieg's mir dann richtig auf so da ist
er da ist keine sd karte drin exzellent gut dann wo ist es hier anschließen flop sd karte
rein und power on wenn ich die sd karte finde hier zack raspberry pi netz teil auspacken
und dann machen wir das ding mal an so leute ich muss mal kurz das kabel rein stecken dass
wir uns gleich habe ich vergessen habe ich ssh angemacht leute habe ich ssh angemacht
ich glaube nicht oder ok dann muss ich die sd karte noch mal rein machen kacquade sd karte
noch mal rein machen was haben wir hier sdb mount touch ssh so also ssh ansonsten kann
ich mich nämlich nicht einloggen huppst an mounten sollte ich vielleicht noch sonst kann
ich mich nämlich nicht einloggen über ssh auf dem raspberry pi das sackt ziemlich so
zack sd karte rein ich guck gleich chat weiter sd karte rein netz teil warum sind eigentlich
bei kabeln die verpackt sind immer so komische so komische das sind ja keine richtigen kabelbinder
so so dinger drum gewickelt die man immer erst raus fuddeln muss gut strom so ich stöpsel
mal ein machen netzwerkabel dran
so
so ich hab die steckdosenleiste die billy china steckdosenleiste runter geschmissen
da hängen natürlich zig kabel dran die werden jetzt auch alle fast vom schreibtisch wieder
die geräte runter gefallen top so so raspberry pi geht an loggen wir uns mal drauf ein
ne mach ich net ich guck im dhcp
so mit den diet pi ausprobiert was war das nochmal das war dieses dieses special betriebssystem
mit mit mit vorkonfigurierten sachen ne hab ich nicht ausprobiert wüsste ich jetzt auch
nicht wozu ich das brauche
gartenstelles video habe ich schon aufgenommen vor zwei wochen
so mal gucken wie schnell die ist ob das jetzt halbwegs funktioniert das war das nicht das
mit vorkonfigurierten sachen wo ich wo ich die die die daseinsberechtigung nicht so ganz
entstanden habe verstanden habe warum soll man also was wusste sinne davon also was brauche
man
schule optimisern gut das ist das das ist das normale auch simple interface ja dann brauche
ich net
ne seh ich für mich den vorteil jetzt nicht drin ehrlich gesagt was kann das tolles wofür
ja heute schneestell geiler aber ich habe kein bock das noch soll ich jetzt nicht da
müsste ich jetzt das video jedes mal neu aufnehmen wenn ein bisschen mehr schnee fällt
das ist ja auch nicht den zweck der sache welche virtual maschinen wäre zu empfehlen
wenn man nicht viel machen vor der workstation ist das beste auf dem desktop
ansonsten wenn du gar kein geld ausgeben willst nimm halt virtual box andere möglichkeit
hast du unter windows ja nicht
ja doch hyper wie aber das auf dem desktop ist tolle kacke weight
oh das ist die sd karte ist wahnsinnig poggers geschwind
wobei das liegt gerade am download das liegt nicht an der sd karte
es gibt forever nicht free es gibt virtual box free
es gab mal den alten forever player gab es free alternative du kaufst dir bei irgendeinem
key shop einen key für einen apple und ein ei
aber auf dem desktop ohne scheiß finde ich am besten
irgendwas was virtual box nicht kann was man braucht weiß ich aus dem steg greift nicht
aber die frage kommt öfters wir haben schon öfters nachgeguckt und ja es gibt einige
dinger snapshots kannst du auf jeden fall auch
machen ich weiß es aber aus dem steg greift nicht
mehr ne ne ne vor allem bei workstation 16 pro
kein player es gibt den player der was kostet es gibt den
kostenlosen player alter das ist ja wahnsinnig geschwind
auf auf gib gas so jetzt jetzt ich bin mal gespannt ich
habe hier nämlich so nen adapter von der weile gekauft usb 2,5 g
zwar der da ist er gab es mal gab es mal billig bei amazon
den hatte ich mal bestellt er war mal in irgendeinem sale drinne für 35 oder so habe ich mit
bestellt ich bin mal gespannt ob der auf dem raspberry
pie überhaupt geht ich mein 2,5 g kriegen wir nicht drüber
ich frage mich ob der überhaupt link erkennt da dran
keine keys schicken im chat wird jetzt gelöscht
vielleicht hast du es gesehen dann guck rein aber ansonsten nicht
als monka toss ihr könnt euch die keys besorgen wo ihr wollt
ist mir vollkommen wurscht aber dann im chat posten
weil weil man weiß ja nie
also ich habe mein key hier gekauft das schwankte mal der preis ein bisschen
software kong ultra vertrauenswürdiger shop
elix critical information das ist wahrscheinlich bisschen so was wie pc fritz oder so
hast du dein key mal geguggelt nö dann weiß google ja bald key
ne kann durchaus sein vielleicht haben die mir auch von github was verkauft kein schimmer
das kann ja sein software kong haben die haben die haben den impressum
haben den impressum
ivan ivan kresic kresic alles klar software kong
ok die sind aber legit sonst hätten die kein universal schlichtungs stelle.de
alles klar ja die sind schon die sind legit aber klingt halt erst mal nicht so software
kong
du kannst mmoga also g2a habe ich schlechte erfahrungen gemacht mit windows keys da habe
ich mal einen geholt vor einer weile also jahre her aber ging dann nicht
ja aber zum thema backup also die hier kann man echt empfehlen wenn ihr wenn ihr nicht
viel speicher braucht und 6 euro für terabyte schon vollkommen in ordnung ihr könnt es
auch als s3 mountain was das ganze sachen noch einfacher macht also während er jetzt
update kommt noch mal kurz chat fertig was für ein teil tts ist es text to speech ne
das wäre tts tss next gen weke platforms engineer klingt poggers ja was neben habe
ich doch gesagt also kommt darauf an was du machen willst wenn du nur so machen willst
nimm sing sing oder nimm sie feil oder was es da noch gibt muss google einfach mal was
es für sing geschichten gibt es jede menge open source dinger die allemal besser sind
als next cloud next cloud also ich finde next cloud lohnt sich wirklich nur wenn man entweder
die basic kombination braucht also aus sing und web interface und kontakte kalender und
sowas wenn man wirklich dieses gesamtpaket braucht allerdings darüber hinaus gehen dann
auch nichts weiter weil die zusatzapps sind halt in der regel unfertig und ziemlich crap
ich meine man darf nicht vergessen die notizapp vor next cloud hatte glaube ich bis zur letzten
version noch nicht mal eine suche das sagt glaube ich alles wenn der notizapp keine suche
hat bis vor einer version ernsthaft ja gut wie gesagt menschenrechte sind in china eh
nicht so groß so hoch angesehen kein wunder dass jetzt hier plus plus machen aber wegen
der sd card ja gut kann man machen aber wie gesagt die samsung endurance sd ssd karten
mikro sd karten sind echt sind echt nice und man die jetzt kauft ja ja gut ublog kannst
du aber nur verwenden wenn du einen browser hast also die meisten leute die phol verwenden
oder phol hört sich in beiden aussprachen nicht richtig an die das verwenden die wollen
es ja meistens auch unter anderem um ios apps werbung zu blocken und so und das geht nicht
mehr dafür war das richtig gut geht aber nicht mehr ok die käumen muss ich mir gerade echt
auf den sack ich muss mal kurz was anderes machen was gut was kann ich stehen geblieben
sind acht chat es macht hier immer noch nicht fertig ok die sd karte ist echt nicht schnell
ja dafür ist es echt gut auf normalen seiten funktioniert es auch meine sache mein also
das problem was ich habe ist mit ich hätte am liebsten dass es auf youtube und twitch
das auch noch gut macht und da ist es halt das sind die mittlerweile hinterher und den
dns blocker kann auch nichts dagegen machen wenn der content und die werbung von den gleichen
servan kommen ich setze keine cookies
also sie musste das glaube ich auch nur machen wenn es personalisierte sachen enthält einschließen
und 24 sieben vom rechner hocken easy und hoodie aufziehen nicht vergessen
ich habe alle daten auf dem nas außer games greife einfach auf die netzlaufwerke zu ja
kann man machen kann man gibt es verschiedene ja also verschiedene taktiken ja also ich
finde beispielsweise nicht so toll die daily sachen auf nass liegen zu haben einfach weil
die zugriffszeiten uns schon unterschied ist ob es lokal ist oder lokale ssd oder übers
nass gehen muss und gerade für gameplay recordings hatte ich probleme gehabt weil das auf übers
nass teilweise zwischendurch fremdrops hatte weiß auch nicht so genau warum vielleicht
weil er seine sind das patch mb die sekunde oder so nicht recht los geworden ist so hat
er jetzt abgreif gemacht ok rebooten wir installieren erst noch mal so die standards sachen die
man immer braucht kann man nicht viel falsch machen so mal kurz durch scrollen stonks leute
hier wieder am start seit gamestop seit gamestop sind auch alle gamer big stonks menschen geworden
habe ich den eindruck ich weiß nicht wovon ihr es habt aber view frontend dotnet backend
ist big brain ist meine absolute lieblingskombination das kannst du nicht es sei denn du findest
irgendwas wie wasabi was du direkt mounten kannst bei dir im fallsystem ja wie gesagt
massive big brain setup also das ist das ich meine das habt ihr im prinzip auch nur gemacht
weil es geht nicht weil das irgendwie dafür also nicht weil es irgendwie für oft seit
backup erforderlich wäre ihr wolltet gucken wie es geht und habt gemacht brauchen tut
man das ja nicht ich muss euch ehrlich sagen ich habe noch kein bgp über vpn oder irgendwas
jemals gemacht ich weiß was es ist ich weiß übrigens gar nicht nach welchem schema so
autonome system nummern überhaupt aufgebaut sind hat mich auch bisher nicht großartig
interessiert für für private anwendung ich installiere aktuell linux drauf auf beiden
dass ich morgen meine neuen switcher testen kann das war es eigentlich dann mal morgen
weiter ich kann jetzt nur mal schnell den chat durch ne ne wie gesagt workstation pro
welche transfer rate hast du das haben wir mal ausprobiert vor einer weile ich weiß
es nicht mal wie viel zwar wenn ihr wollt können wir das noch mal ausprobieren ich
meine ich habe eine ich habe ich habe zwei ssd hier liegen und irgendwo habe ich auch
mein ssd adapter können wir noch mal ausprobieren wenn ihr wollt es ist es ist nicht wahnsinnig
hoch halt das was man über usb 3.0 so drüber kriegt also wie viel das war kann man gleich
mal ausprobieren schreibe ich mir auf pass of exile ich muss erstmal die league wieder
spielen ich hatte überhaupt nicht großartig bock und auch nicht großartig zeit die letzt
leagues zu spielen ja die liefern sich so ein bisschen ist bettel stimmt warum eigentlich
nicht ich glaube habe ich ausgeschaltet wegen wegen was auch immer wegen wegen letztens
irgendwas habe ich letztens gemacht wo ich darkmode ausgeschaltet habe gibt es irgendeine
totale oder eine art anlagen für für totnet und vue js also nee aber eigentlich hängen
die zwei sachen gar nicht so großartig miteinander zusammen also es ist es ist es ziemlich egal
in was sein backend was sein frontend ist also das eine hat mit dem anderen nichts zu tun
ich meine du könntest das backend austauschen und die gleich das gleiche frontend verwenden
also du musst ja nichts spezielles machen in dort net und dass du view verwenden kannst
und umgedreht ich mache wie gesagt du machst das unabhängig voneinander ok progress die
aktuelle league ist nice ich habe ehrlich gesagt gar nicht gar nicht mitgekriegt ich
habe den ankündigung trailer gesehen mit irgendwie dem neuen endboss und das war es
ich habe absolut kein kein schimmer ist sie vielleicht gut für ein fau server um darauf
backups speichern zu können sie fallen für oft sein irgendwie weiß ich nicht ob das so
eine gute idee ist gehen mit ein paar tricks wird es bestimmt aber wenn du backups speichern
willst würde ich das nicht über sie feil zünden sondern ich würde erstmal lokal bei
dir irgendwie auf nass und von dort nächtlich dann auf den server ist glaube ich die bessere
variante wie würdest du eine boomer docker und kupan etis erklären gar nicht wenn der
typ keinen plastenschimmer von der technik ist es unglaublich schwierig das zu erklären
eine erklärung finde ich nicht gut die leute sagen immer container sind wie vms aber doch
nicht was er was erst mal alle verwirrt dazu kommt dass container mit vms gar nichts zu
tun haben container ist ein sandbox prozess das versteht auch jeder mit ein bisschen technik
know-how und erkennt sofort den unterschied zu einer vm leonis container sind prozess
sandbox prozesse und kupan etis ist ein orchestrator für eben sandbox prozesse für leonis container
ich meine was man was man immer als beispiel bringen kann ist was weiß ich wenn du deine
hardware besser auslasten willst oder oder auch wenn es in der cloud macht wenn du vielleicht
weniger bezahlen willst und du lauscht irgendwas es greifen 200 leute am tag drauf zu irgendein
großer youtube channel macht mal ein video drüber und auf einmal greifen 5000 leute
in der stunde oder so drauf zu und dann ist natürlich cool wenn du deine anwendung relativ
easy skalieren kannst dafür ist was wie kupan etis super aber und das darf man nicht verschweigen
das alleine macht die skaliert die anwendung immer noch nicht also sprich die anwendung
muss auch so gebaut sein dass die ordentlich skaliert diagonal natürlich also über horizontal
und vertikal skalieren sind wir schon raus wenn wir skalieren allgemein nur noch diagonal
ne seafile habe ich mir nicht anguckt soll ich das mal machen können ich machen wo habe
ich es denn hier streamideen so seafile exzellent so das haben wir geupdatet reboot bam wo ist
wo ist meine usb netzwerkarte meint ihr der raspberry pi hat da überhaupt treiber für
so ein ding das ist doch schon ein bisschen was schnelles ein bisschen was spezielles
nicht schnelles schnelles auch wenn es geht spezielles was ist da was ist da für chip
drin sieht man das weil das eigentlich egal ist wenn es über usb geht schauen wir mal
gucken wir mal ob es funktioniert stimmt das in usb netzwerkern braucht ja gar kein spezielles
so schauen wir mal so erst mal erst mal ssh copy id jawoll muss ich den chat hier oben
lassen sonst weiß ich nicht wo stehen geblieben bin jetzt können wir uns einloggen ohne passport
sehr gut so da ist es und ich muss mal kurz schauen wir mal in dem mess konnte man da
eigentlich auch so was wie f machen oder so folgen geht das das geht ja wahrscheinlich
netter aber gibt es nix eingebautes wäre cool wenn es das geht aber das minus weh ich wusste
doch dass das irgendwie ging genau exzellent exzellent siehst du das sieht man mal wieder
warum mein chat der einzig wahre die leute sind mittlerweile so big brain durch die ganzen
subs dass ich eigentlich gar nichts mehr wissen muss ich muss einfach was sagen und der chat
weiß es 500 IQ chat ja so und schließen wir das mal an und gucken gut das hat jetzt vielleicht
den falschen anscheinend erweckt weil das hat jetzt den anscheinend erweckt als habe
ich jemals irgendwas gewusst ich mache jetzt schon immer stream ohne ahnung zu haben so
also ich stöpsel das mal an mal gucken ob er das jetzt erkennt register oder wird aber
ganz schön heiß wie switch zu zwischen windows und linux control windows taste links und
rechts feil du kannst nämlich unter windows verschiedene desktops machen ich glaube das
kennst du wahrscheinlich das gab es also jeder hat schon mal gefragt was macht der knopf
da unten ganz verschiedene desktops machen und mit control windows und feiltasten kannst
du dazwischen switchen und hier habe ich einfach eine vm offen auf dem zweiten desktop also
sprich ich switch einfach die desktops und auf dem zweiten desktop ist die vm offen was
für mich die deutlich bessere variante ist als dual boot und auch die bessere kombination
als umgedreht windows unter linux weil linux unter windows läuft einfach 1000 mal besser
als windows unter linux so ähm wo habe ich das netzwerk kabel ich war netzwerk kabel
ja exzellent exzellent netzwerk kabel mal kurz gucken das ist das da liegt so da liegt
nämlich eine ikea tasche drauf auf dem netzwerk kabel mit ähm allen kabels drinnen gucken
dass ich das jetzt rausgezogen bekomme ja ja komm komm her komm her auf jawohl sehr
gut ups fuck ich bin angeblieben warte mal ich mache mal das headset ab ich stöpsel
mal an gucken ob das zünkt hey oh oh das ist nicht gut leute da stimmt was net das ist
ich habe mal wieder rausgezogen ok das ist definitiv nicht normal das ist definitiv nicht
normal was das zünkt was zum da crash der netzwerk treiber oder
irgendetwas der fährt sich die ganze zeit hoch und runter aber guck mal der holt sich
die ich leute ich trau dem frieden nicht ich trau dem frieden nicht das stimmt doch was
nicht so ich ziehe jetzt ich ziehe jetzt mal die eigentliche netzwerk karte raus und
ich wette dann bricht ab auch hier unten hier sind wir eigentlich über die zweite netzwerk
karte verbunden hier unten aber ich wette es bricht ab auch wenn ich die ja ich bin
nämlich ich bin nämlich nicht wirklich über die über die zweite netzwerk karte drin doch
bin ich moment also das ist doch definitiv nicht richtig was passiert hier eigentlich
gerade eiperf ich habe keine gegenstelle zum eiperfen eigentlich alles gut ich habe keine
gescheite gegenstelle zum eiper doch habe ich mein nass mein nass nee ich wollte irgendwas
ich wollte irgendwas mit 10g haben meine vm macht ja maximal 1g wobei wartet mal wartet
mal die vm ist 1g aber wir könnten mal nass probieren wir testen es erstmal so
das leckt aber es fack ok netzwerk demask spam
wir googeln mal danach spam spam login ist das log Leute wir sind nicht wir sind nicht
die einzigen das problem haben f für 30 millisekunden ja manually compiling instanti
ich wusste ernst ihr wollt doch nicht dass ich wirklich im netzwerk treiber da jetzt
kompilier für oder das kann doch nicht euer ernst sein ok das ist ubuntu aber das ist
bei bei dem jahren bestimmt genauso ok ich kompiliere den treiber aber jetzt wir machen
erstmal ein eiper habe ich hier bei mir übrigens lokal auch drauf muss mal gucken ich habe
den usb netzwerk adapter 2,5 gigabit usb netzwerk adapter der irgendwie nicht so ganz funktioniert
das spammt ja als fack aller ok wie war das jetzt eiperf es
ich kann mir das immer nicht merken genau minus s und jetzt war das eiperf minus c was
habe ich hier für eine ip liegt leute wie der ip liegt war das so ok ok also der treiber
funktioniert muss jetzt mal aufpassen dass ich nix leake
oh shit ich hab mein key nicht da drauf ach nee das ist ja auch max please ha bäm eiperf
also über 10 g in anfüllung strichen das hat selbst zu wenig pc express performance
kein quake warum geht das nicht ihr habt recht leute ihr habt natürlich recht der chat weiß
wieder bescheid ich sag doch 500 iq chat warum ist das schlechter alter warum ist das auf
dem c warum ist das auf der kiste mit 10 g schlechter keck weight was hatte das ding
ist aber für der ip keck weight aber retry alter oh was da kaputt aber umgedreht nicht
oder aber ihr habt ihr habt ihr den namen von der kiste gesehen da freut sich der chat
bestimmt ok wir testen noch mal wir testen noch mal den speed zwischen
connect ja gut da ist volle pulle also sofern es halt vor der vm geht stimmt minus er hast
recht habe ich ganz vergessen ja das geht auch von windows aus kann man übrigens nicht
genau ausprobieren weil die iperf implementierung von windows kaputt ist
pass mal auf iperf implementierung von windows ist kaputt ach so ja lull die hat trotzdem
keine 10 g anbindung hier ja ich habe ich habe nichts anderes auszuprobieren also könnte
meine 4 he kiste starten mit den zwei 10 g karten drin aber das muss jetzt nicht muss
jetzt nicht sein ich könnte höchstens die 10 g netzwerk karte von meinem desktop mal
kurz anschließen aber dann bricht wahrscheinlich das stream ab weil er wieder nicht checkt was
sache ist ok also das schauen wir uns mal wieder aus also die netzwerk karte glaube
ich können wir schon mal sagen die funktioniert prinzipiell aber die hat so ein paar probleme
mit empfangen könnte auch das usb vom raspberry sein
das wird ja immer mehr sagt man wird das mehr wenn man was überträgt moment cake wait
wird das mehr wenn man was überträgt nicht wirklich oder probiert auch mal die usb karten
direkt an einem rechner zum nass oder ist eine gute idee wir können usb wir können
die usb netzwerk karte mal durchreichen an die vm das könnten wir tatsächlich mal probieren
oder was machen wir jetzt mal gucken mal gucken was dann was das das probieren wir mal aus
mal gucken was passiert ich gehe mal kurz hier was war vom pai raus und macht mal ein
rechner dran ist das ein usb port nee moment ich brauche usb 3 port das ist 2 0 das ist
3 0 glaube es passt nicht ein haus sonst kackt das stream wahrscheinlich ab an die vm hoffentlich
checkt er das wenn man das direkt bei durch pest an die an die vm hat irgendwas erkannt
rename usb ja da erkannt passt und der spam gar nicht kommt mal ich habe hier den aktuellen
treiber hier passt das was für ein switch router wird getestet einen mikrotik 8 port
2 10 g also 8 1 g 2 10 g und 4 port 10 g so usb wo ist die usb netzwerk karte das da
ist das die usb netzwerk karte von der benahmung her wird es die einzig sinnvolle wahrscheinlich
ne also if konfig minus i boah das habe ich schon lange nicht mehr gemacht haben wir hier
zwei punkts keck weight was ist ein freie 87 bestimmt ab ne ach fuck wie ging das noch
mal so alles klar if konfig weiß aus dem kopf wenigstens halbwegs ok alles klar so dann
probieren wir das ganze mal zum nass er hat jetzt probleme mit der netzwerk karte oder
was wartet mal wie hieß dieses kack ding noch mal ok da hat echt problem mit der netzwerk
karte jetzt muss ich ihm bloß noch sagen dass er diese netzwerk karte verwenden soll da
ist wahrscheinlich das beste ich mache einfach temporär die netzwerk karte mal aus das glaube
ich deutlich einfacher kann man den man kann ich kann ihn einfach disabel ich kann jetzt
einfach disabel im netfuck manager so ist jetzt weg jawoll excellent up ping ah ja sehr
gut so jetzt sind wir sind wir drauf 231 alles klar ja das sieht auch schon moment las log
in 87 alles klar iperf dings minus c ja ok das sieht jetzt schon ein bisschen besser
aus ich meine sind nicht wirklich 2,5 muss ne 2,5 sind nicht aber man sieht auf jeden
fall es ist mehr als eins das ergibt dann das ergibt schon sinn wie ging das minus
minus er zum umdrehen das stimmt irgendwas nett das hat irgendwie
ein bisschen probleme mit senden kann das sein das kann ich sein das ergibt keinen
sinn warum sollte so probleme mit senden haben genau den chillfreak egal wir kompilieren
uns jetzt den netzwerk treiber für für die respiratory pie ich ziehe das erstmal wieder
raus hier wagen die netfucking an ja ist er weg ok alles klar er ist das ha was hat denn
er wieder spend ok wir wissen ernsthaft den netzwerk treiber sebex hast du das teil also
wenn du das gleiche problem macht dann sagt wahrscheinlich einfach nur hardcore das teil
ok linux treiber hier realtek die realtek website sieht ja immer so super vertrauenserweckend
aus ja ok mac os mac os linux wo ist linux da download der massive firmware probleme
dann brauchen wir mal den hier download kann man das kann man das direkt was realtek seid
hier noch bei sin ja moment was zum skr k x dark patterns alda hier
wunderbar wenn ich jetzt schnell bin kann ich vielleicht den download link cram und
direkt hier reinhauen jetzt die frage ist das ist das da dabei
48 k was ist denn da gz ok das ist anscheinend echt ok bundeship ist es nicht da xf zv
ja was weiß ich denn das ist das
ta einfach nur in ta ta x tracked 8
moment der hat das hat er das jetzt
der hat das vorher schon extrakt oder was
so da ist er der realtek treiber so jetzt hat sich die preisfrage wie geht das ich muss
bestimmt erstmal bild essential installieren sonst wird es wahrscheinlich auf jeden fall
nicht funktionieren weil wir brauchen bild essential ist schon installiert ok gibt es
da einen guide zu read me wer liest wer liest denn read me in 2020 read read me also was
muss man if you want support s5 woll
wupp z wir haben dafür bringen sie maut ich bin gerade über mein headset gerollt jetzt
auf der einen seite nicht mal nur wartet mal
so alles gut exzellent exzellent okay also was was wollen was wollen die von
mir also wir brauchen kein break on lan fedora vor ubuntu na wir haben wir haben
ja keine ubuntu wir haben den raspberry pie in debian aber okay das ist ein
example muss man einfach einen make machen jetzt einfach einen make da drin
oder was
was zum
wir kompilieren hier make modules haben hier eine ordentliche anleitung für drinnen
make modules okay das funktioniert auf raspberry pie anscheinend nicht
ich bräuchte kann hätte installieren oder ich muss kein sudo make install machen
weil make install kann ich erst mal wenn er was kompiliert hat install ich muss
bestimmt können hätte das oder so installieren könnte ich mir vorstellen
weil der sagte er findet irgendwie keine er sagt er guckt hier nach lip modules
irgendwas und da ist nix
erst mal ein bisschen wasser das könnte man vielleicht mal die read me
reinschreiben ein bisschen besser was man machen muss
spari pie compile realtech driver okay
mk d
ja linux herr das habe ich doch gesagt genau
Okay, okay, wir gucken wir gucken einfach mal
Aller der spammt ganz schön rum ne
Ach so ich habe gar kein t-max darauf auf jetzt installieren wir machen wir hinne
Oh hier wirds big brain jetzt gleich noch
alter raspberry pi come on wo ist das problem
Zeig mal her wo ist das problem
Ah ja exellent exellent okay so make ha sieht besser aus leute sehr gut es kompiliert
und wir wissen ja alle wenn es kompiliert dann funktioniert es auch
sehr schön so und jetzt was muss man jetzt danach machen und der mod minus
ach nee after installing okay hoffe ich einfach mal okay nice wir machen das einfach mal wie es in der readme steht
ja cheat 95 mir bleibt gar nichts anderes übrig weil guck mal meine netzwerkkarte spammt ein bisschen
und was muss noch den da machen boot image okay und jetzt reboot ich mal und dann
Mist ich bin ein kack noob ich hätte habe ich noch drinne war habe ich noch die ausgabe
beträchtige mod probe mal gucken ob das reicht aber wahrscheinlich muss ich den alten unloaden okay wir
rebooten mal das hat nix
so und jetzt mal gucken ob das jetzt weg ist ich muss den alten treiber bestimmt noch bestimmt noch
blacklist oder irgendwie sowas was er wie ist das ding warum nicht
so
Irgendwas drin
Fuck
Wo ist denn
Ich war doch mal wie heißt das andere die aber wenn ich den jetzt unloade dann habe ich keine netzwerkverbindung. Ja
Was ziemlich sagt aber dann mache ich einfach das kabel wie den respiree pysaps rein
Ja gut dann machen wir es mal
Das ding wird heiß alle leute
Whatthef
Ich krieg das kabel noch mal raus
Das netzwerkkabel geht nicht mehr raus
Das ist fest geschmolzen oder so keine ahnung
Was das
Das muss ja nicht raus reißen
monka es
Was das für ein kram
Fest gelöt
Was hatten wir für eine lp die da
Ah ja sehr gut sehr gut
Wie ist das ding
Oh
Wie soll das jetzt funktionieren er
Kein schimmer alter
Ist das so okay
Er ist in use ja klar aber ich könnte ich ja doch können genau ich kann es einfach abmachen wir hoffen dass es dann
Tja anscheinend braucht man das auch für das normale zeug das funktioniert schon mal net
Das kann durchaus sein dass die internen usb hängt
Was wie ist das ding jetzt noch mal was ich da hab 5 2
Der sollte das aber eigentlich
Genau das gleiche problem habe ich auch genau das gleiche problem habe ich auch kann man hier mit minus v oder irgendwie sowas machen
Der lautet das nicht
Was muss ich machen leute sagt mir forum please
Schreibt einfach was ich machen muss
Als ernsthaft diese scheiß forums antworten immer so weißt ihr so nach dem motto es geht nicht
Ja aber leute wo ist denn überhaupt der sinn warum möchte man sowas denn machen
Können wir das mal erklären ist doch komplett used das warum willst du sowas denn machen geile forums antwort immer alter diese spazten im forum
Wie hat er den kram denn jetzt überhaupt hingekriegt dass er den scheiß lädt
Wie hat er das dann hingekriegt wie hat er das dann hingekriegt dass er das lädt
Wie hat er das dann hingekriegt wie hat er das dann hingekriegt
Geiler tipp exzellent exzellent genau das das ist das warum ich 2,5g gekauft habe
Also eigentlich müsste das eigentlich müsste das damit schon gehen weil damit müsste das beim booten laden so macht er aber nicht
Also eigentlich müsste das damit schon gehen weil damit sollte das beim booten laden weil damit sollte das beim booten laden
Kein plan was sie von mir wollen
Das sagt das sagt gar nichts ist lustigerweise ist nicht geladen und bei einer mod probe sagt es danach auch nichts
Obwohl es keine fehler gibt witzigerweise
Was ist das problem ich fürchte das wird immer gebacken
Ok was macht der du make bla bla bla sudo mod probe das funktioniert bei dem auch
Das haben wir auch schon gemacht
Was minus groß war auch minus groß ich weiß nicht wo der Unterschied ist aber
Das ist wie gesagt das mit den placklisten habe ich mir auch schon gedacht wo ging das noch mal etc modules das muss das muss doch
Irgendwie anders funktioniert ich will nicht den einen geboten ich will den anderen verwenden
Ja genau ok forum zeichnet was sinnvolles
Ich meine letztendlich die adapter funktioniert ja prinzipiell aber
Ja wie geht das genau wie geht das erzählst erzählts mir das haben wir alles gemacht clone
Ja das haben wir alles gemacht haben wir auch gemacht
Ok das probiere ich jetzt mal aus wo haben wir das denn hier drin
Ja also da jetzt big brain hier kommt jetzt also das ist typisch das ist typisch
Linux big brain geschichte also ok alles klar machen wir das da
Aha aha nano null weh alter nicht spiel nicht nano ich glaube es geht los
Was zum was wie jetzt ok mache ich ich macht es ohne scheiß ich weiß gar nicht wo es los geht
Wo geht es ja los ok linux kram teilweise ok null bda und dann das hier 8156 ich hoffe mal das stimmt
Das meinen die nicht ernst oder
Ich habe ich habe put image updaten vergessen hast du gegen nano nix jeder kann hier verwenden was er
Will aber mein fall ist es nicht ja log ich ein blies raspberry pi ich muss gleich pennen
Ich wollte sagen dass plus ist blutet jetzt nicht mehr so jetzt wollen wir gleich gucken ob der jetzt irgendwie beim anstecken was was was neues macht
Immer noch der gleiche scheiß ja gut ob das jetzt ob das jetzt reicht
Das kann ja ernst sein das checkt doch keiner
Es bleibt nicht mehr steckt ja auch nichts steckt ja auch nichts drin
Ok das muss man anscheinend so machen
Das habe ich schon ok ok dann stöpseln um
Ok es macht jetzt gar nichts mehr das interface
Oh fuck es blinkt wieder es blinkt wieder wie verrückt monka es das ist nicht das ist nicht weg
Scheint hochkomplex zu sein das ganze
Ne da lebt das auch gar nicht der habe ich schon habe ich doch gemacht
Hab ich doch schon gemacht
Und jetzt Rebooten noch mal Quatsch bringt gar nichts und ich doch eben schon mal
Unload jetzt ernsthaft was weiß ich wie so eine kack ding erstelle
Du kannst das nicht löschen wenn das aktiv ist da braucht das andere wahrscheinlich für den für die on board
Netzwerk karte und chat hört mal auf zu backseaten mit dingern die schon vor 20 minuten ausprobiert
Hab so geil es nicht funktioniert ok das gar nicht irgendwas hier in der in der
Dings weil das kannst du nicht das kannst nicht löschen ist in use ja klar so
Ja aber das das witzige ist dass das ja auch nicht funktioniert aber das liegt
wahrscheinlich dann weil das andere schon geladen ist ich glaube das liegt
nicht am patch das funktioniert glaube ich auch so
Github Github kommt zeige ich her die Frauen Herren Agile genau hier hier
Big Brain Manjaro Post die Blacklisten ne ne ich will den nicht
Blacklist ich will ihn doch laden kann ich den anderen einfach Blacklist kann
ich den anderen einfach Blacklist wobei das ist das ist doch jetzt so eine so eine
so eine art Geschichte oder ich probiere ich probiere das jetzt einfach ich
Blacklist jetzt das eine und wenn es dann ne Moment Blacklist muss ich das
andere machen wie ist das andere cdc so
jetzt 25 es gibt ja ist richtig
was ist das da alles wait a minute was ist das da warum ist er warum sind da so
dinger drin ist aber irgendwas anderes
ich rieche jetzt noch mal ob das jetzt was gebracht hat
wahrscheinlich nicht
wahrscheinlich hat es alles nichts gebracht
in die rule muss doch das aktuelle gerät was ls usb ausgibt
moment da gibt's was das das probieren wir jetzt aus ok geht durch durch was
das cp was macht das ding 50 das brauche ich alles klar excellent
weiß zwar nicht genau was es macht das da cp nach was oder rules ok perfekt etc oder
ich rieche jetzt trotzdem einfach nochmal so mal gucken das könnte
tatsächlich sein dass es fast bringt da hätte ich mir nämlich den ganzen
anderen crap sparen können im zweifelsfall sogar eher kontra
produktiv ist auf riebute ich will nicht dass es leht weil wenn es leht dann ich
habe vergessen wenn es leht dann stürzt es ab ich weiß nicht mal wie das ging
muss immer so lange warten weil ich glaube ich habe es kaputt gemacht es
geht gar nicht mehr das kriegt es kriegt kein link mehr
ich habe jetzt so viel plack listed ich glaube ich habe zu viel plack listed
ich hätte gleich die udorf rule kopieren sollen
der kriegt jetzt gar kein link mehr
moment ich mach mal on board ich mach mal on board wieder dran ob
on board wenigstens noch geht nicht dass ich on board jetzt auch plack listed habe
das war 230 und noch ich habe ich habe die on board auch noch plack listed
ane ha ha ha okay das geht noch ich glaube das ding war einfach nicht
richtig gestartet kann das sein das kriegt kein link mehr leute
sinkt das ding kriegt kein link mehr ok ich lösch den scheiß mal wieder den ich
da in modules gemacht habe das war mal jetzt schnell noch und dann
gespennt so etc modules ne mod probe was habe ich dafür für
ein crap gemacht rm gleich mal wieder so ich hoffe einfach mal die die die udorf rule funktioniert
tut das noch
ich dachte eigentlich können wir gut ich meine wir können auch ohne probleme damit morgen mal die
switcher testen weil ganz ehrlich ob das bemt oder nicht ist doch erstmal egal wobei da auf
jeden fall irgendwas nicht stimmt da verliert wahrscheinlich zwischendurch die verbindung
so ok jetzt stöpseln um noch mal aus long hat jetzt irgendwas geschrieben hier vorn was war
das r8 noch was guck mal guck mal jetzt erkennt dann oder auch nicht equate
ok ob
er nicht findet ich check nicht aber ich stöpseln noch mal um und jetzt pochern pochern
pochern da kriegt kein link das ist geil da baut jetzt einfach keine verbindung mehr auf
ist auch top ich gucke mal in meinen router rein ob der jetzt andere dhcp sich gezogen hat
oder so vielleicht das ist knoam terminal dhcp 30
jetzt kriegt er mit der udorf rule kriegt er kein link mehr ist ja auch geil
top ok drauf geschissen wisst ihr was leute zack zack ab damit spary pie aus können auch
die switcher morgen ohne ohne das ding testen hat mir nur gedacht das wäre cool zu gucken ob
das ding auch 2,5 g kann soll ich gucke jetzt noch mal schnell chat ich habe bestimmt sich
sachen übersehen halt irgendwas wichtiges übersehen habe sagt noch mal bescheid was
ich muss firmware update machen rc 12 auf fack alles schlimmes ja sorry alles ab die ich übersehen
habe nice dankeschön dass ihr gesagt habt massive subscriptions wieder bin ich mir sicher ich habe
gerade irgendwie mein fenster verschoben ich gucke gerade noch mal schnell den haben wir
dann am start hallo hat subscribt aber falle keck weight ja so sieht es aus big brain subscribt
vor 54 und auch bei dir hoffentlich platzter kopf demnächst massive IQ boost danke für die
ganzen subs habe ich noch was übersehen kloomstick den hatten wir schon nice tja vielleicht kriege
ich das morgen hin mit dem mit dem treiber mal gucken ich habe eine power inter plattform
nix besonderes low power internet plattform 80 euro fürs mainboard inklusive cpu software
0.2 server 0.2 server drauf und sonst alles mögliche was ich brauche aber nix nix irgendwie
kein proxmox kein unrate oder irgendwas 0.2 server drauf docker compose für ein paar sachen
die sprach samba server fertig reicht das ding kriegt er eh maximal 5 g hin weil das hat
zu wenig pizzi express lanes es hat zwar eine 10 g karte drinne und auch eine ssd die ordentlich
was packt aber die pizzi express lanes reichen nicht für komplettes 10g es ist quasi 5g
das kann sein ja sind einige aus dem chat dabei gewesen
den besten türstopper den wir hatten waren 15.000 euro san switch ok der hat bestimmt
jetzt auch keine 15.000 euro mehr gekostet als wir ihn als türstopper hatten der war
nicht umsonst türstopper ok leute also jetzt mein soundtrack nicht wir sehen uns machts
gut bis dann see you